be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life stuff
the so continuing our series on
omega-level mutant what I wanted to do
here is focus on the powers of Quentin
choir also known as kid Omega created by
Grant Morrison and appearing for the
first time in new x-men number 134 from
his initial appearance while Quentin was
stated to be an omega-level mutant this
was not designed to be a focal point of
his character nor was he designed to be
a long-term member of the Xavier
Institute instead his appearance
actually came out of Morrison's desire
to reshape the x-men team under the
direction of editor-in-chief Joe Quesada
as part of the revolution relaunch
because Quezada wanted to ensure that
the stories of Marvel maintain their
classical themes but still resonate with
the young readers of their target
audience under Morrison the x-men team
maintained its classical roots of
fighting against mutant oppression but
the stories are written to allow for a
wholesale expansion of the mutant
concept giving way to a more in-depth
look into not just how the x-men
function as part of the larger superhero
community but the goings-on of the
struggles of each team member as well as
the larger issues facing the Xavier
school to this end Quentin represented
the generation of readers born in 1995
and leading up to the 2000s who found
themselves rebellious due to exposure to
a combination of Technology and blooming
social media by way of MySpace and other
websites as a result and according to
the in comic classification offered by
Xavier Clinton's powers were comprised
of telepathy with unrealized omega-level
potential in addition to this while
Clinton was not a social outcast in the
traditional sense he did form an early
jealousy towards a fellow student named
slick as well as a crush on Sophie of
The Stepford cuckoos now again this
represented the coming-of-age struggles
between those trying to fit in and those
who had already found their place but
offers the adjustment of young mutants
being able to use their powers as a
means to even the playing field
at the same time Quentin's arrival
coincided with his birthday during which
time he received a call informing him
that he was actually adopted with no
real information forthcoming on who his
actual parents were this revelation
combined with Sophie refusing to notice
him and his failure to live up to the
image of what other students considered
to be cool said Quentin into a state of
borderline madness
adopting the physical appearance of a
mutant Overlord as it had been described
in an op-ed news piece which was written
by ball of our Trask some years earlier
Quentin also began to experiment with
kick the street name for a drug known as
hyper cortisone D which boosted the
powers of those who used it by a factor
of five now starting to point out here
is that this bit of information
originally existed as a source of
contention among fans regarding whether
Quentin was actually an omega-level
mutant or simply elevated himself to
that status through artificial means
where this would be expanded on with
Greg patch story Phoenix and so on and
kick itself would later be revealed to
contain the essence of the entity
sublime the fact remained that Quentin's
mutant powers of telepathy were boosted
to the point that he exceeded those of
both Charles Xavier and Emma Frost
christening himself kid Omega and coming
to the conclusion that Xavier dream of a
peaceful coexistence between humans and
mutants was nonsense Quinton formed a
group called the omegas who alongside
himself began the process of avenging
mutants who had been killed by humans in
a fashion that fell almost directly in
line if Magneto's ideals in addition to
this with the Xavier Institute hosting
an open doors policy for family members
who look to spend time with their
children
Quentin and the Omegas launched a riot
and took over the Institute subduing
Xavier with a helmet that blocked his
telepathic abilities while the ride of
Clinton was felled by way of Xavier
Spellman being removed and The Stepford
cuckoos using kik alongside cerebro to
enhance their hive mind telepathic
powers with grant Moore's and having
already introduced secondary mutations
Quentin was effectively written out of
the Marvel landscape when his mutation
evolved due to his use of cake
transforming him into a pure state of
energy that said the notion of Quentin
choir becoming an omega-level mutant
organically came with Phoenix and song
written by Greg Pak as a send-off to
Jean Grey the story also served the
purpose of providing a means to tie up
loose ends for both her character and
the rest of the x-men team to sidetrack
here where Morrison was working to
revamp the team for modern readers the
other half of this equation was also
removing characters who for a lack of a
better word had run the course but the
case of Jean Grey
following the original Phoenix and Dark
Phoenix saga is under Claremont her
character had quite literally fallen to
the wayside due to various writers being
unable to keep her compelling in the
eyes of fans while keeping from
rehashing the work of Claremont and so
it's part of his larger
vision Morrison effectively wrote Jean
Grey out of Marvel Comics in two phases
beginning with the es for extinction
event coming out as Morrison's first
story arc with new x-men following
Cassandra Nova's massacre of 16 million
mutants on the island of Genosha after
which she infiltrated the Shiar empire
while posing as Xavier Jean Grey was
left to run the Xavier Institute on her
own as the headmistress using this as a
means to create a rift in the
relationship between Jean and Cyclops
Morrison placed Emma Frost as a wedge
between the two that effectively
destroyed the relationship when Jean
walked in on Cyclops having a psychic
affair with Emma who was posing as Jean
following this the final blow came with
the introduction of Quan Yin Zone a
mutant under the influence of sublime
and posing as magneto for the purpose of
creating chaos within the mutant
community and presenting mutants as a
legitimate threat to humanity as opposed
to a peaceful race while the x-men and
Zorn's own followers doubted his claim
to be the real Magneto and it never
Dupree was claims a fight was instigated
in New York during which time Zorn
killed Jean Grey using an
electromagnetic pulse that disrupted the
electrons in her brain now where Jean
largely remained absent following the
conclusion of Morrison's run because his
final story concluded with the arc here
comes tomorrow which featured Jean Grey
from the future with Chuck Austin doing
little to answer questions as to why
Jean appeared in the future despite
having been killed the writing duties
felt a great PAC reused and song to both
clear up these questions and others
including what happened to quentin after
transforming into a pure state of energy
now with this bit of storytelling Greg
Pak removed the kick-ass back of
Quentin's powers and elevated him to
being a full-fledged omega-level mutant
within song centering on the Shiar
empire resurrecting the Phoenix force
the entity travelled back to earth and
Inever to locate Jean due to the fact
that she was destined to become one with
the entity stumbling across Quentin
choir Greg Pak established that Quentin
was an omega-level telepath making him a
potential house for the Phoenix force
while Quentin was not chosen the side
effect of his exposure to the Phoenix
force drove him to ream aterial eyes his
own body effectively resurrecting
himself now while this does not seem
like an OLE feat of telepathy with
uncanny x-men number 282 by John Byrne
titled his name is Bishop the first
appearance of Lucas Bishop and Marvel
Comics
came with the introduction of mind
transference or the ability for
telepaths to either reconstitute their
own bodies or transfer their
into other host bodies where this is
usually used as a plot device designed
to allow powerful telepaths to be raised
from the dead the fact remains that it
does have precedence in Marvel Comics
and was used on several occasions prior
to Gregg patch story but regardless with
Quentin being confirmed as a possible
house for the Phoenix force because only
telepaths of the highest cosmic order
are capable of this Greg pack had
effectively offered up the idea that
Quentin was omega-level and well beyond
the capabilities of all known telepaths
with the exception of Jean Grey as a
result of this and while the story saw
Quentin returning to his noncorporeal
form the work of pack also introduced
the notion of Quentin possessing
telekinesis
well beyond some of Marvel's most
powerful villains and heroes including
apocalypse Nate gray Vulcan Psylocke and
mr. sinister now following Greg packs
story various writers of the x-men began
spinning out a series of stories that
involve quit Inquirer and depicted him
as an omega-level force who remained
unchallenged with the exception of
cosmic entities and Franklin Richards
where Quentin remain largely absent from
Marvel Comics for around six years and
2011 under the writing of Jason Aaron
and Karen Gillan he returned to the
Marvel landscape in physical form during
the Schism event continuing the fallout
from 2004 house of M which reduced the
mutant population of 198 schism
initially focus on the introduction of
Cade Kilgore born as a human with gifted
intelligence that rivals some of
Marvel's most intelligent heroes Cade
Kilgore had frequent inquire using
Quentin as it means for Cade to kill his
own father and overtake the Hellfire
Club using his considerable resources
and working alongside Quentin choir the
two laid waste to the x-men with both
Wolverine and Cyclops taking different
stances on how Cade and Quentin should
be handled where this leads to a schism
within the team allowing Wolverine to
form the Jean Grey school for higher
learning in Westchester New York because
the powers of Quentin were so extreme
instead of allowing him to be taken
prisoner by Captain America and the
Avengers
Wolverine petitioned Steve Rogers to
allow him to take Quentin under his
tutelage as a student and the hopes are
both instructing Quentin on how to use
his powers adequately as well as keep
the increasingly extreme measures of
Cyclops from using Quentin as a means to
wage war against humanity written by
Jason Latour and coming out of volume 2
issue number 1 is part of Marvel now in
2014 Wolverine and the x-men revealed
that whether by choice or circumstance
at some point in the future the Phoenix
force would return and seize control of
Quentin quire due to his status as an
Omega level telepath and telekinetic
following this where Quentin had several
subsequent appearances the most notable
display of his powers came during the
battle against Cyclops school and the
all-new x-men
taking place as a continuation of
Wolverine and the x-men vol 2 because
the methods of Cyclops had become more
and more extreme under the writing of
Brian Michael Bendis Hank McCoy had
traveled into the past and retrieve the
original x-men team under the hopes that
the younger Cyclops would talk sense
into his older self where this would set
the stage for the events of Avengers vs.
x-men and the return of the Phoenix with
the conclusion of the Battle of the atom
storyline seeing the original x-men team
taking up residence with Cyclops at his
school in the old Webber next facility
Quentin discovered and battled the
entirety of the school's inhabitants
taking everyone out with very little
effort seeing the appearance of his
future self as a host for the Phoenix
force within the eyes of fans they have
two previous despues of his powers were
not enough to guarantee his position as
a mega level this did now while this was
short lived because Marvel was
continuing to move towards the launch of
Secret Wars and the start of all-new
all-different marvel
Quentin with virtually all loose ends in
terms of the mutant community were tied
up during axis centering on Red Skull
acquiring the minds of Charles Xavier
and resurrecting the onslaught persona
the full capacities of Quentin choir
were put to the test and his attempt to
shield the x-men and the various heroes
from the mind of Red Skull while the
heroes attempted to organize a front to
destroy Red Skull where this eventually
failed and Quentin was discovered the
purpose of this bit of writing from Rick
Remender served to confirm that with the
exception of collective entities like
onslaught or cosmic constants like the
cosmic entities or Franklin Richards
there was virtually no one on earth
capable of rivaling the abilities of a
fully powered Quentin choir
with that being said we're going to
bring this video to an end and let me
know how you guys feel about Quentin
personally he's a really good character
but I also think he occasionally falls
short of good storytelling but with that
being said I will catch you guys later
peace